all right you guys are here first time
nominee for the show how are you feeling
today because last time we talked you
were right you were like i'm ready to
see you in person oh my god this is a
thrill
yeah this is amazing because we shot the
show so long ago and it's to relive it
now and to celebrate it is i mean it
feels really good yeah it's a big thrill
for me you know i gotta ask when do we
start shooting season three there is
stuff that we need to know there are
stories that need to be told i have
questions
i have questions
are you going to answer those questions
daniel henderson
last night my mom said yeah son i see
that your character is homeless in his
car
i'm like
eating peanut butter sandwiches
you can't go nowhere like what has
happened well i think first of all let
me say i'm really thrilled that the show
is going to have a third season where
and also we're absolutely going to be
celebrating season two tonight because
what an extraordinary effort to put it
together i mean we did that during a
pandemic and it was extraordinarily
difficult but uh what i'm so happy about
is that we're all here as an ensemble
yeah because we really are a cast that
um loves spending time together
and it's just been
an amazing journey especially for me
getting to work with karen getting to
work with like so many top notch actors
and actresses in our show being led by
women an opportunity for in the show for
you to really try and change the game
and how we view television so we're
really excited to get to well i've
already seen janine i've seen mark i've
seen lester like y'all here
we are here
it's going to be a big table and if we
get to go up there fingers crossed it's
going to be a long line of people
by the way can we talk about miss booked
and busy here and just like that
as well everything yeah okay last time
we talked to any news on season two
we've talked to cynthia we talked to
everyone everyone says we're do we want
to do it we want to do it we want to do
it that's still it i think that they
still want to do it we're trying to
figure out a way out i think they're
trying to figure out a way to do it i'm
not actually the person to give you the
good answer that's sarah jessica parker
michael patrick king but listen if
they're doing it i am right there i am
anything they want me to do it's such a
great time a great show i did read the
other day tell me if this is true or not
that you were actually supposed to be
miranda's love interest listen michelle
i did not know that you didn't know you
told me that nobody told me you didn't
know you was gonna have some female 1 oh
that could have been sexy y'all that
could have been that could have been
super sexy
me and cynthia nixon maybe yeah she
could get it ah she can't get it she
could get it
i mean listen
the the scene with her insider
i don't know if y'all would have done
that
i don't know
kitchen works for you uh saturn
they could definitely get it listen
they're hot i mean okay but
would you listen sada's gone off to
california i mean we know she's going
but miranda could turn around and come
right back home could it happen listen i
think that dr wallace is very much in
love with andre rashad
and uh they're married
andre is a good man very fine as they
like to say
[Music]